what effect is it having um
on you as an actor
before the video starts guys check out
our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
so then i'm sitting in the tent watching
the director do his work
and the voice says salaam and
well this is what happened next
yeah i can speak english i don't know
good or not but
i can't speak and i can understand you
fair enough it's nice to see you
thank you very much you have a very you
have a really intensive
filming schedule i don't envy it yeah
yes it is
you basically live in this environment
and also it's
a very hectic program i
always work at six days a week
it's too much
i wish for you a break but not for the
for us viewers a break
thank you
what effect is it having um on you as an
actor
how have you grown uh what does it mean
to you
to be doing a project like this at this
time in your life
it's a very big project
and also it's the first time in turkey
it's like
like this big production and then
to tell the muslim people
it's very interesting but i was very
excited when i saw
the first episode it was very nice
the first episode it's very good and
also
i know my director so he's my
old friend and he's the best
and
i was excited and it was a good role for
me because there is a lot of
toys you know like uh yeah right
yeah yes did you have anything did you
learn to walk right here did they train
you
i did i know yeah yeah i knew i knew
when it was child's eight years old or
maybe nine years old i was right
are you a cousin no but my
i'm suitable but my grandma's
has a farm to near the
city so the weekend we went there
so i knew
i i find it very interesting to hear
words like inshallah
you know do you know that people uh
muslims in the uk
are being revived because of this set
of what you're doing here do you feel
the weight of history on you yeah of
course
if you not feel the history you cannot
uh play like that
because it's you need to feel some
something
and i've we all failed
did you i knew could you expect at the
beginning of this to make a faith-based
film every week
in turkish language and you know
not english for it to be such a hit
around the world
or did you do
wait of course for this success
it's it's very big success now so you
knew
maybe the build has a
two pages the news uh
not built a metro metro in you know the
metro
yes yeah they had a two
page of news to the dearly shark turtle
they said if you don't want to wait uh
game of thrones you can
watch that's how i came to it
yeah it's amazing
you